thank you
foreign
thank you
thank you
foreign
thank you
thank you
foreign
foreign
yeah I like that bro y'all better smash
that like one bro for that now make sure
you guys watch this stream till the end
we have another subscriber alhamdulillah
that wants to take a shahada and become
a Muslim so Sunny fast bro you're more
than welcome to be a part of that if you
want to witness that
um or if you don't want to no pressure
bro when we're done the stream in about
an hour we'll just bring that subscriber
in now how has your life been since we
last got you on the stream bro what's
new it's been good it's been it's been
hectic you know we just drove across the
country up north
um been doing a lot of business stuff uh
this ended a partnership with somebody
it's been a really stressful couple
weeks but it's been pretty good
okay on the left bro I'll praise to the
most high how's your mom doing
my mom's doing good she's over there
right now I'm in the living room of my
family house up North so it's there's
people cooking meatballs my grandma's
walking around
so it's a funny background behind the
camera you guys are Italian right
yeah yeah okay so what do you guys do
what do you guys think about time what
do you guys think about the pizza and
pasta in the West
the pizza and pasta on the west well New
Yorkers are especially weird about it
like they only like New York Pizza and
then when they go outside they kind of
complain everything's not like New York
but
um it's it's good that's like some of my
favorite foods Pizza and Pasta
okay okay
are you how are you boys doing today
doing good man doing good
on the
okay so before we jump into this do you
any of you guys have anything that you
want to bring up any questions anything
that is on your mind before we Jump
Right In
how's the uh the Quran reading going man
have you gotten a chance to uh it's open
now yeah so I've opened it up I I've
I've barely read much of it yet so far
to be quite honest
um it's on the to-do list to you know
dedicate like some of my time to move
through it every day but it's good thank
you guys so much for the gift to greatly
appreciate it of course of course Nora's
man you just gotta even if it's like you
know two pages a day just gotta make
room for it that's uh something I
learned in over time
yeah 100 percent
it's definitely helpful having the you
know
um the translated version it would have
been a little tough to read yeah
absolutely absolutely and we're here you
know if you have any questions about it
awesome yeah it's it's been crazy yeah I
mean I still get hundreds of DMS a day
so it's tough to respond to everyone I'm
sure you guys get the same thing where
people light up your DMs especially with
us it's like a million different videos
to react to so it it's hard to respond
to it all like all my comments like I I
have a business account for my agency so
all I have is it in my bio and now
people go to my Instagram bio click on
that one and then DM my business account
oh no it's it's funny but it's cool guys
don't do that don't do that don't mix
the business and uh in like the
religious uh YouTube stuff please let
the man be has his own business
um please so last time last time we uh I
think we focus mainly on your mom and
her views and that stuff and I think us
and the viewers realized that there
wasn't a lot of time allocated to you to
talk about your beliefs what you
currently believe
um you know what you think about Islam
and um your journey with that you went
into it a little bit but um I I want to
ask you what do you currently believe in
if anything
so at the moment I'm not like my mom's
super Christian but I I don't you know I
don't go to church a lot or any of that
but then I'm also not you know a Muslim
obviously but I don't you know follow
Islam or anything I'm still kind of
where you you do good
um and that comes back around to you I
haven't like picked one religion I'm
still kind of just researching around
um to kind of you know make my final
decision
but it's definitely been a crazy Journey
looking into Islam because my
perspective of it has changed completely
from you know the start of when I even
watched the first video like back then
it was still you know the typical
American point of view where I knew
nothing about it I didn't realize they
were both abrahamic religions they you
know
they both believe in the same God
essentially Jesus is in the Quran like I
would have never known that so it's
definitely been a really cool Journey
but for what I believe in I still don't
you know identify with one specific
religion it's more of just like a you
know you what goes around comes around
you do good what what good energy you
put out there comes back to you
I see all right all right very beautiful
I think a lot of people nowadays have
that kind of it's almost like karmaic
belief you know yeah
so and I can see where it comes from you
know people love the idea of justice and
fairness and that stuff uh which I think
is beautiful so this opens up the
question
um let's you say you're looking to
different religions how do you think you
would critique these different religions
like let's say you look at Christianity
Islam Buddhism different ways of life
what criteria would you use to determine
one is true and and another is not
hmm that's a good question so I I
definitely agree with how
in like you need rules and stuff so I've
definitely you know like a lot of the
points you guys make Tate makes is that
with Christianity it feels like there
isn't as many rules anymore people can
kind of just do whatever they want and
that's why I kind of haven't you know
been you know as a following of that
lately especially even with like the
girls and like one of the red flags I
say is like if she has Bible quotes in
her bio or I can watch you out you know
what I mean like stuff like that and
then
um
I don't know
let me ask you a simpler question
because I I had a feeling because I
think this question trips up a lot of
people it's like categorized yeah they
categorize categorize religion and in a
different aspect in a different realm of
Truth like if you wanted to come to a
truthful conclusion in this world about
this world in something in regards to
physics or chemistry or or whatever it
is even if you want to find out if like
you know your mom or dad went to The
SuperStore today
how would you figure something like that
how would you come to truth in the
physical reality that we live in so I
guess the answer a lot of people would
say is like physical proof or something
like that where there's hard evidence
but I guess that's a lot tougher with
religion because a lot of it's before I
guess like nowadays it's like a cell
phone footage you know what I mean
that's what a lot of people would say is
hard proof that something happened is
video but then even with that you can
only believe half of what you see so
going with religion where that's it's
before video and you have to take you
know multiple people's visual accounts
and what Scholars written down
um hmm I mean it is it is definitely a
tough question I'd say what like what
has stuck
um as facts for the longest amount of
time to be quite honest not something
that's changed constantly like that's
that's also why I respect Islam a lot is
because the book hasn't changed once and
the rules haven't changed at all it's
the same thing since the very start
absolutely 100 and when when we look at
truth in in or outside of religion um
you could call it physical proof um but
that kind of I think reduces it to
something that you can physically see or
touch right now currently
um but when you look at for example
things like historical records or you
know what we believe happened
historically it becomes a little less
physical and I want to open up the
conversation to something that's not
inductive induction is based on
observation physical reality
um something called deduction
if I lived in if I was currently in
Spain and I told you I went to the
supermarket in Canada today you would
not believe me because it's a
contradiction for me to be in Spain one
day in that same day I'm in Canada at
the supermarket and thus the travel time
equates and it makes sense that way but
without boarding a plane right let's say
that would be a contradiction so that
would not be possible
so I want to make your life easy okay I
want to make your life easy
when it comes to all the ways of life
the only two it really boils down to is
Christianity
and Islam
all the other major religions fall into
a kind of either it's ethnocentric like
Judaism you have to be ethnically Jewish
to be religiously Jewish otherwise the
long drawn out conversion process
to be
um uh for example Buddhism doesn't deal
with God at all right or it barely does
it's just literally just a way of living
your life in the middle ground and so on
and so forth on who could probably tell
you more about that and then when you
look at Hinduism it's it's a
nationalistic religion it's a
nationalistic religion there are people
as far as don't even really convert to
Hinduism they're born into it so when
you look at all the different ways it
really just comes down to Islam and
Christianity because those are the only
two religion religions where we're
taught to go out to the people and
preach for them to come and accept Islam
or to come and do apologetics to get
them to come to Christianity and now uh
to make it really simple if you go to
the Quran and see what it says and you
go to the Bible and see what it says you
don't have to really worry about the
physical proof and evidences if one of
them falls into a logical contradiction
and a great example that I think like um
gives a lot is like the numerical
contradictions in the Bible or who
witnessed an event or what what were
Jesus's last words when he when he was
on the cross the Bible and the different
gospels have different accounts of these
things
so
if you find that one place has all these
contradictions that cannot be reconciled
and another one doesn't and it has a way
of life that is conceivable
then you're basically only left with
with that one option so
you know when you venture out and go
learn different religions I would say
keeping that in mind is very important
and not to limit yourself to kind of um
the the arguments that you just hear
from people and um to what you can
physically see like oh why can't I see
God I think that's you know Silly thing
that people fall into
so what do you think of that did that
make sense no yeah that that definitely
makes a lot of sense
um so
I that that brought up a question that I
have because you're saying how there's
no contradictions in the Quran
um but there are a lot in Christianity
so what for the longest time like the
scientific scientific miracles in the
Quran weren't known to be Miracles until
they were really realistically
scientifically proven like I mean you
know a lot of them like the mountains
being seen as pegs
um sperm looking like a leech is that
what it is
it's like basically the the embryo at a
certain stage looks like Alicia so what
were those perceived as before they were
approved like those
those messages in the Quran but because
like for thousands of years nobody knew
what that meant essentially if we didn't
have the proof of it does that make
sense yeah absolutely absolutely so some
of these things actually are not seen as
a we're not seen as some kind of
scientific phenomenon the one about
embryology there's no way around it that
is very clearly talking about the
embryological development of a human
being
um and that is basically as far as I
know seen as Verbatim what the text says
first they they go in this state and
then in that state then to that state
and then later it's just proven because
science is a realm that is constantly
changing right so there was a time in
the scientific method and induction that
stuff didn't even exist so the Muslims
would just take it as a word of God it
must be true you know first they're like
this and then they go to that then they
grow into this that must be the truth we
didn't they didn't need scientific and
uh you know inductive explanations and
proof of it they just accepted it but
you also have some verses and some
things that people claim to be
scientific that people never looked at
in a scientific manner
for example
um
one thing people actually like to say oh
this is an inaccuracy in the Quran is
one verse that talks about the where
human beings come from Allah says in the
Quran let man reflect on where he came
from from a a gushing fluid
and then it says stemming
from between the backbone and the ribs
now people like to say oh sperm doesn't
come from the backbone in the ribs you
know that doesn't make sense
and when you look at the classical you
know interpretations of this verse
before the induction and all that stuff
and before we knew about all this you
find that what it's actually talking
about some of the scholars the way they
interpreted it as it's talking about the
human being itself when they're born
they come but from between the backbone
and the ribs of the mom you know coming
out the womb now people are trying to
not now like this it's also classical
um you know interpretations as well
they're saying like we had a episode of
Thomas he's talking about there's a an
area called the semical vesicles that is
between the backbone and the ribs
seminal vesicles seminal what did I say
semicolon semicol on my bad seminal
vesicles thank you
um that literally lies between the
backbone and the ribs of the men and is
responsible for most of the fluid that
comes out when the man ejaculates so
my point is there are different
interpretations some are scientific some
are non-scientific and um
you know that I think should open your
eyes up to the different realm of
interpretation not everything that
people say scientific actually is but
some actually might might have that
capacity to be interpreted that way yeah
that's definitely a good point because
at every point and in history you know
when you go 50 years ahead of time or or
later down the line you look back and
you're like how do they believe that it
happens every single time like even you
know you could go to any point in
history and be like well they believe
the Earth was flat like and then like us
you know having more scientific
knowledge in the future we look at them
like dummies meanwhile if we were born
in the same time we think the same exact
thing yeah 100 100 and what I what I
really love about Islam is I honestly
think it it always slaps the um you know
the contentions and the people with the
contentions in the face when you look
back it always slaps them in the face
because there was a time when they
believed the sun was stationary
right maybe 100 years ago or 300 years
ago the Quran 1400 years ago said that
the the sun has its own like orbit right
so if you go back to the time when
people Europeans in the west they
believe the sun didn't have an orbit
they would they probably look in the
Muslims and say look at what your book
says that's incorrect and now we know
that the sun even though it's in the
center of you know our galaxy and stuff
or in the center of our solar system
part of me it still has an orbit so the
Quran was right you know the prophet
peace upon him there's a time when he
said the body has 360 joints and there
was a time more recently when it wasn't
360 it was like 350 something and they
found the actual joints and they said it
was 360 joints and the prophet piece
upon them ended up being right So
eventually it always comes around and
kind of smacks the the you know these
these Islam haters in the face anyways
hmm interesting
yeah very interesting I have another
question does the Quran talk about equal
and opposite forces sort of like Ian and
yang
um the closest thing I can think about
is when a
a man came to the process
and he asked about hell and why it
exists or something along those lines
and the prophet sallam said when you
have the night don't you also have the
day or when you have the day don't you
also need the night basically saying
that yeah you do have to have an
opposite for certain things like for
good there will not be good if there
wasn't any evil you know what I mean
yeah there would just be action so
that's a close thing I can think of but
um
no mention of this kind of Yin Yang
there needs to be an opposite kind of
thing
yeah I mean there's a bunch of reasons I
asked that because I kind of that's what
I you know how I look at my life a lot
of the time when I'm going through
something hard I'm like there's no good
without going through this hardship
right now you know if everything's good
nothing's good realistically it's all
just whatever and then also because a
big reason Tate said that he he switched
from being an atheist to Islam and
finding religion is because he
recognized there's equal and opposite
forces and he could see the true evil in
the world so I was you know I was
definitely curious about why um
what's it called
oh my sound is muted on my shirt
whatever but yeah I was curious about
the equal forces in Islam it's very
interesting
yeah a lot of people watch the video of
Tate and then they they kind of go on
that bandwagon of things
you know we were talking about it one
day that they think that shaytan or
Satan the Devil is kind of an equal and
opposite Force to Allah stop for Allah
we know that's not true it might be
opposing but it's nowhere equal because
at the end of the day Satan still
believes in God still puts Allah God
over everything else but it's just the
arrogance and pride that he wants to go
against Allah's will yeah yeah 100
um the more I think about it the more it
depends on what you mean because I don't
think evil and good are opposite in in
any way to be completely honest other
than like opposite ends of a spectrum
you know if you have like zero being
evil 10 being good then they're on the
opposite ends
um but they wouldn't be evil because I
would say there is a time when good in
the world was triumphant and beat the
amount of evil in the world and there's
a time like nowadays where the amount of
evil overtakes the amount of good being
done in terms of actions and and what
people believe in all that stuff
um so I don't think they're equal in
that sense but what we what we know is
that
when truth comes falsehood vanishes
right if I'm if I'm trying to argue to
you that the Earth is flat and you find
the evidence that it's round anything I
say is completely Adventures like stop
talking you don't know anything it's
very clear now that's what we believe
about the truth about good and about
whatever you know God has sent down that
becomes clear so
really at the end of the day what you're
left with is is either ignorant people
or arrogant people who do evil auctions
and so on and so forth
but at the end of the day we know that
Allah spent Allah God himself will hold
everybody into account and anyone that
did Evil did it against them their own
self and anyone that did good did it for
their own self and that's how we view
you know evil and good in Islam now
you're only doing good against uh good
for yourself or evil against yourself I
like that that's a good way to look at
it
um I have another question and if you
guys want to ask me stuff too just feel
free but I wrote down some stuff so I
know that you guys don't eat pigs and
stuff because they're dirty animals can
you kind of expand upon that and I'm
just asking these questions because like
this is the stuff that you know a lot of
Americans would wonder when looking into
the life of you know Muslims
yeah yeah so I want to talk about it
from the same perspective then I think
five might be better versed on it it's
kind of the health you should we're
supposed to talk about how it's not just
Muslims bro
that's a great point that is a very good
point I know Sunny fast said you guys
and I know I know you you see that
because I don't blame you bro Muslims
are a force today that that we actually
follow what's written you know but this
is not to throw they're on any other
religion but it's actually not something
that just stems from Islam 1400 years
ago it's actually just something that's
always been a part of God's law
but so why pigs specifically other than
animals like cows or chickens
yeah so firstly I want to give an
Islamic kind of explanation so Allah and
the prophet peace be upon him
when anything is made Haram we're told
not to do this you know this is Haram or
we told we're told to do something and
we need to do it we aren't always given
a reason right for example
the process doesn't always say this is
Haram because of this and because of
that so that leaves room one for us to
just say Allah is the most knowledgeable
Allah is is the all-knowing and the most
wise if he says something is Haram it's
for a good reason and I will obey God
because I submit to God and his will
and sometimes there is a reason given
but when there isn't it's up to us to
basically extract wisdoms behind it you
know if I were to eat pork this might
happen that might happen this could
happen and this could be from the wisdom
of why God did not allow us to eat it
and I think if you've read the studies
you see that pork is a tremendously
horrible thing to eat for you it's not
good for you yeah for your health and
fine if you want to go into that and
talk about some of the uh the cons to
eating yeah I mean guys I can I can do a
lot of research that I've compiled
before and I can just put a link in the
description but simply put the way that
pork is preserved the way it's handled
when you look at like you know FDA
regulations on Animal Control when you
look at you know just the bacteria when
you look at the pathogens that it has
the way it's prepared when you look at
sausages
um I was even even in TV shows bro like
there was this one TV show called house
and it's like a medical show a lot of
people watch it you know these are
mainstream shows and it just shows one
kid that just ended up in the hospital
and they couldn't find the cause about
it but they found out that for a long
period of time they were having
basically pork like just sausages you
know and the way it's preserved Frozen
it it's a very dirty type of meat what
do you expect from an animal that eats
its own fecal matter you know what I
mean
yeah you can't be surprised when you get
sick
it kind of ties into a lot about like I
wanted to play a video bro it's a quick
like two three minute video it's nothing
too long I think Anna already knows what
I'm about to play um but it's something
that I like showing a lot of people
because not Muslims bro they come into
Islam and they wonder why do you guys
have this thing called halal meat you
know what does halal meat is it just
like something that's like blessed you
know why is there so much segregation
you know meat is meat some people also
think that okay if you guys are Muslim
you don't eat pork cool at least you
know you guys eat chicken right you guys
eat beef but we have a specific way of
slaughtering the meat which is halal
meat I'm sure you've heard about it
um so I do want Rami to talk a little
bit about halal meat
um if you don't mind and I'll just put
the video up bro inshallah
all right so halal meat as far as I know
it's just it's meat that's slotted in a
very specific way as according to Allah
and his messenger revealed and with
basically the name of God and Praises of
God being recited um when the animal is
killed so you'll find in a lot of these
places that non-muslims that slaughter
their animals some that even claim to be
you know practicing Muslims or
Christians or whatever they they have
disgusting disgusting disgusting
um you know regulations and very very
disgusting
uh what's it called
methods of killing the animals yeah
that's crazy exactly methods yeah like
bullet in the head and you can see the
animals are strong losing its mind and
and going crazy right before it's dead
in Islam we don't even let the animals
see the blade in our hand
we separate it from the entire flock and
we take it into a place where it's alone
we basically get it to lie down we cover
its eyes we get it so that's relaxed we
recite a prayer it doesn't even see the
blade and then it's just a quick slice
of the throat and the arteries here and
that does a few things one I I don't
know if this is how accurate this is but
I heard that it cuts off a certain nerve
so the animal doesn't feel a certain
pain or something I'm not sure if that's
that's I've heard that recently and
secondly it allows the blood to flow out
because diseases are carried to the
blood so the more blood you drain out
the cleaner the the meat is going to be
and you're not going to have all those
hormones of the animal freaking out you
know poured into the meat and that stuff
like I've heard recently it happens a
lot bro that's that's facts 97 to 98 of
all animal related illnesses are
bloodborne
but I do want to hear you know what you
were going to say now but we're
basically going to show you like a
demonstration of what a halal meat
slaughtering looks like
and and how the animal literally submits
like there's no cortisol in the body of
the of the animal and we want to get
your thoughts on that but what are you
going to say bro
no it's just it's really interesting
stuff
um
what was I gonna ask I'm blanking right
now I'm such a dummy sometimes you can
just play the video it'll come back to
me no worries bro no worries inshallah
it's been a long day
no I gotta I get it so I'm just air
dropping the video it should take
another like I remember what do you guys
think of vaccines in Islam
because that's what sticks with your
blood for years and that's what you know
can can change your blood a lot it's
getting all right so no no no questions
on the JibJab
on this yeah on this channel that's why
we got our first uh strike but here's
the thing bro if you want to have a raw
unfiltered conversation about that we
can post that on our website so we've
actually been thinking lately of posting
more unfiltered uncensored things that
you know we can't really say on every
website and post it on our Channel
inshallah I think it being centered kind
of tells you what you need to know but
yeah we can do that separately but I'll
put the video right now
take a look at that
okay
okay
God's blessings and mercy upon you all
my human brothers and sisters today I'm
going to share with you a video an
amazing video of two parts
about the authentic Islamic Slaughter
procedure on lambs and goats on the
first video we're going to illustrate
the power of God's name as the only
method of submission before Slaughter
on the second video we're going to show
you the authentic Islam the complete
authentic Islamic Slaughter procedure
only using God's name upon Slaughter
exactly the same way the all the
prophets have done for thousands years
Abraham Noah
Moses Jesus and Muhammad peace upon all
of them not using stun guns or hammers
or any other equipment's electrical
equipments only using simply only using
God's name upon Slaughter
before we proceed I would like to
mention that all the scriptures Torah
Bible and Quran has been preaching of
one God he is the CR he is the only
creator of all creations and he is the
one that worthy of being worshiped and
thanked by all his creations and he also
created lambs and goats as a blessing
for humans
for the purpose of food and clothing
the scriptures also preaches about
Humane treatment of animals and as a
humans we only have the right to
slaughter him in God's name to be
mentions before Slaughter God's name can
be mentioned in different languages and
it will have the same effect you can say
God's name in English Arabic Hebrew
French Chinese as long as the slaughter
have a strong faith in the word itself
and of the Creator and mention it it
will have the same effect in the same
submission effect of the animals it's an
amazing word and it will have the same
effect in different languages
these animals are bilingual and they all
know God's name when it's mentioned no
matter what language and they always
feel the heart of the slaughter if he
believes in that word or he doesn't
wants to believe in there the faith is
there and the word is mentioned is
guaranteed affect and a guaranteed
submission
part of stuff
let's go
we're gonna take these animals run them
inside as a group we're not going to
separate an animal from each other
um
every animal every Creations would like
to have a partner except the almighty
Lord so to really maintain these animals
to be calm you always have to trap to
make him travel with a group you don't
separate anyone from the other
definitely not one by himself that would
really make him very tense it has to be
two or more minimal okay what we're
gonna do we're gonna take the uh
bring him over here and we're gonna make
him submit
on the ground obviously yeah
[Applause]
I just want you to like just look at how
calm it gets bro like there's no
cortisol in the blood
is what happens when you get super like
ramped up and scared right
yeah yeah
this is total submission
total submission this guy is ready for
anything wow
be done to him and he's not nervous he's
not resisting
he's in total relaxation
no Panic hormones whatsoever
see I let him go he gets up
if you want to do them you need to show
to a skeptical person
okay baby it's okay I'm not doing
anything good
Bismillah
it's okay baby
screaming got me
same reaction they all react the same
the power of the word
[Music]
they're more religious than most humans
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
awkward
Bismillah
[Music]
total submission
these guys had a little uh
be coming from a bigger ranchers so
they're a little bit wild they're not
used to be touched and handled by humans
and uh for them to turn around and just
lay down like
really in total peace
answering the calling
definitely
the power of the word my not
[Music]
ES
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
it weighed over 300 pounds
and it's usually
get away more now because he was fed and
he's been having fun eating Alfalfa and
everything he's probably 10 pounds
larger than what it was in the office
I weigh 190 pounds
so any dealing with this guy he has to
help out otherwise there's no chance
anybody can really restrain him or force
him to do anything that he doesn't want
to do
he's going to do exactly what he
instantly wants to do
so if this guy submits
the power of the word is clear
this is a 300 pound animal for me to
drop him down on the floor to start
submission it's almost impossible for
one person to do it
for the initial submission and then he's
gonna withdraw and the animal is gonna
respond by himself
[Music]
[Music]
a big boy
yeah
it weighs more than me
[Music]
I'm putting only a finger on the ear
and this guy if he wants to get up I
don't think any anybody is capable
to get him back down except two people
as strong as me and Abdullah
to be able to submit this animal on the
floor but now
he's totally answering the calling
and he's happy with it there's no
breathing hard if you know that
I think I got the idea that's that's
really interesting it's it's pretty sad
to see that and then think about
how that's how it's like kind of meant
to be but how
in the you know the big Industries and
industries and stuff it's the complete
opposite and they do horrible things to
the animals that's right
I've never seen that that's wild
when you look at like animal production
today you know McDonald's Burger King
all these different you know Mass
consumerism there's no way they can
invest in that bro in halal slaughtering
like that to make the quick Buck whereas
you know stun guns and machines and
factories if you if you really watch the
documentaries about how they keep
chickens bro there's there's like a
certain amount of square footage that a
chicken should have to have an optimal
life you know and they have I think like
two or three chickens per square foot
that's like the amount of room they get
yeah no it's it's insane I've seen a lot
of those documentaries it's horrible
what they do
100 and it's this is a very clear
example of how things should be done
versus how they actually are done but
suddenly think about all the other
Industries in life where people are
doing it completely wrong you know think
about for example and it doesn't have to
be like a business industry think about
things like intimacy
think about the average person making
money and how they make money you know
this whole like interest and debt uh
based Financial system that we have
um everyone's being promiscuous with
everyone and anyone day to day to day to
day and they don't care and question oh
should this be done through the sanctity
of marriage where there's obligations or
responsibilities and Trust put into the
opposite person where you can't just
simply walk away the next day like it's
nothing without any consequence
um or should I just go around and screw
around with everybody I see this is done
with I would say every single Avenue of
life nowadays which is why we are such a
you know dystopia unfortunately
wow this it really is so fascinating
because
I tell people like one of the big
reasons that I want to make a lot of
money is so that when I'm older I can
have freedom to do whatever I want and
teach my kids whatever I want so I want
to make like a whole curriculum where I
have all the most important life lessons
that I've learned and then I teach them
to kids with the Trojan Horse so like a
business lesson I acknowledge it and
then I find a way to teach them that
without them directly knowing that
that's what they're being taught and I
kind of see a similar thing with
religion it's like you follow this and
it's taking you away from all the empty
things of life and every aspect possible
with the way you eat your food with your
sexual life with what you do during the
day it's um it is really interesting
it goes so much deeper than I would have
thought because like even with the meat
like I I I didn't think it would be such
a peaceful way and that it goes so much
deeper and it shows that they're really
submitting
um it's wild
yeah 100 percent
I have another question unless you guys
want to keep anything else on this topic
nope
before before that I was just gonna say
um every everything in life goes deeper
than we think bro everything every
single afternoon life goes deeper than
we think and even like one thing I I
want you to question something I
question myself you know I went actually
we have a video of me going um and
asking some people what their goal in
life is
and for them it's always always you know
make money and become rich and be
independent and and be free and whatever
and I asked them where did this dream
and this this goal come from and they
say it came from myself but the truth is
it did not and I think it's the same
with you you know the idea of oh I want
to be free and and and all this stuff
did not come from you it it does
actually let me put like this your goals
happen to be Financial Freedom and
stability and and physical liberal uh
freedom in life
we just happen to live in a liberal and
capitalist Society is that a coincidence
to you that your goal is the exact goal
that capitalism sets out to do and your
goal is the exact goal that liberalism
sets out to do it's the same as growing
up in a Muslim nation and being well my
goal is to be a good Muslim and please
God wow that's that's yeah that's a
really good way to look at it it's like
people having beliefs that they don't
even know why they believe that 100
program bro it does it goes so much
deeper than you than you could have
thought like even when I started making
these videos it was like the Islamic
programming of not Islamic programming
of what I thought about Islam that kind
of programming like there's so many
different things where you just have
intrinsic beliefs about and you think
that that's what you you really thought
of in your head but it's it's the
complete opposite it was just instilled
in you that's that's a really good point
wow yeah absolutely so these are just
points to you know to reflect on and
it's really good to question why do I
think this why do I believe this you
know can I prove this is there anything
that I can say or think that would
disappear prove what I believe you know
these these are all important things
that every single person has to question
Muslim and non-muslim um but that's all
I had to say uh what's your question my
man
um it's different well no worries
I was going to say what do you think
about people using Islam for views
because I've noticed that ever since
I've started making these videos there's
been like tons of accounts like just
replicating exactly what we do
um and I just wanted to get your
thoughts about that I'm assuming it's
like God knows your intention
yeah no it's it's crazy I just wanted to
quickly jump in and say that I've I had
this thought of reaching out to Rami and
ano in our own little group chat and
being like bro we should talk about this
like new pandemic that we have of like
Christian YouTubers reacting to Islam
for views or and here's the thing
there's a lot of people that are
genuinely sincere but then there's also
people that they know exactly what
they're doing bro their goal is not to
generally learn or or look and Allah
while I'm broke but there are people
let's let's admit it as it is you know
that they want to use Islam for just
Fame and views
oh 100 I mean I I'm not gonna call out
names obviously because I'm I don't need
to start a bunch of Internet beef like a
child but it's pretty obvious it's it's
definitely interesting I I've I've sat
with my mom and we've talked about it um
like our intentions and stuff to try to
make sure we're not just you know
being um
I mean it I don't know I I see like
doing something like that it comes back
around in a negative way
I wouldn't
I wouldn't be proud of you know doing
that
yeah and I generally think like the
sweetness of like Iman like fully having
acceptance of Islam and having that
faith and conviction when you come to
that point bro you realize nothing else
you know in this world is true except
Islam and you almost have this kind of
like Zeal or just this kind of like
empathy towards everyone else almost
like this altruistic like intention you
want everyone to be put on what you're
on so that's why as Muslims we have that
type of like motivation and drive like
you'll see a lot of people bro in your
comment section because they want for
you what they have for themselves bro
it's it's a good comparison I can make
to to that would be like me or anybody
recognizing like the Matrix and like the
programming that you just talked about
but in other aspects like the
educational system and you trying to
wake people like like that's what I try
to do I try to wake people up from that
because that's what I've woken up to but
you're woken up in the religious sense
so you're motivated in the same way that
I'm motivated to wake people up from
that it's a really good comparison
it's definitely really interesting
reminds me
before you do that I was gonna say I'm
trying I'm trying to find the exact
verse but it reminds me of this one
verse that Allah says in the Quran uh
I'm probably gonna butcher this man so
forgive me
uh but he he says something along the
lines of like have you not seen those
who uh they sell a portion of the truth
for a small portion of this life wow
it's like if you only know the uh
the punishment that that uh awaits them
or something like this I definitely
butcher that for sure 100 but I was
trying to find it because it it goes
exactly with these people that are doing
this only for like the views and the
money
yeah and actually I was going to make a
very similar point that in Islam when we
say disbeliever or in Arabic
basically comes from a root word that
means like to bury something so we don't
believe someone who has never heard
about them before is is a disbeliever
maybe an unbeliever but not a
disbeliever you don't know what you
don't know correct exactly 100 so a
disbeliever someone who gets the message
so all these people who are watching all
these evidences and proof that Islam is
true and they see it's true have no
reason to disbelieve in it but still
disbelieve in it they're just setting
themselves up for an ultimate failure
because on the day of judgment Allah is
going to say you've got thousands of
views watching hundreds of videos
proving Islam is the truth and you still
rejected it
and uh what the Muslims lose you know
they watch these videos they try and put
on the best you know Muslim demeanor
they can and comment politely and tell
them you know that's great you should
accept Islam what do you think of this
react to that whatever Muslims I don't
think really miss out on too much the
real loser is the one who sees the truth
and rejects it afterwards that's what we
believe as Muslims
I think in the Bible there's a this
verse if I remember correctly from when
I used to practice
and it goes along the lines of um a wide
game the world and lose your soul in the
process or something like that you know
which one I'm talking about bro
yeah that's that's definitely a really
good point I've seen so many people you
know sell their souls for
for a little bit of clout or a little
bit of money like I worked in the um the
nft niche I mean the nft space and like
I I just like hate crypto now like I
think it's it's all just like a scam
it's it's crazy once you get to um to
see what actually goes on up the back
end of those businesses and everything
it's it's it's Madness
different
nfts are different yeah nfts are even
worse like the marketing strategies that
people would use and then like tactics
like it's it was just I don't know
everyone's scamming each other it was
just like a horrible space to work in so
I'm glad I'm out of that
but that really woke my mind up to how
like people could look at something and
perceive it in their own way when in
reality it's the complete opposite going
on behind the scenes and they have no
idea
I wanted to ask you both uh anho and
sunny about your thoughts on Christmas
anho being a revert to Islam that still
has you know obviously you're coming
from Christianity or Catholicism so I'm
sure a lot of your family members that
are obviously not Muslim you know they
still celebrate Christmas
and it might be a fitness to you if you
want to hang out with them uh so on and
so forth so I want to know about your
thoughts and then I also want to know
about Sonny's thoughts because bro
there's people commenting uh about
asking about Christmas asking about that
Christmas tree behind them got the candy
cane so I do want to know about your
views on that for you guys but before
that
um do you want to quickly just read
these out
uh right we forgot to add to the fact
that during the crucifixion Christ all
his disciples for succim and fled
Matthew 2656 in other words none of them
were eyewitnesses it was all hearsay wow
very good note uh Ismail says does Sonny
know the significance of the Christmas
tree behind them
it's a good question Sunny do you know
the significance no this is although we
can talk about that afterwards uh Top
Notch says inshaallah
Allah guides we will
all right
I've learned Jesus as a talking baby
teach me more
so are we going to talk about Christmas
we're going to talk about Jesus both
let's talk about Christmas
or both yeah
but they're they're called
talk about Christmas first
all right okay
I mean Angel was nice
I was saying the fact you asked Angel a
question so I thought that inshallah he
was going to talk first of all because
yeah I know bro my bad I was I was
completely trying to still find that
verse for Sony bro
no worries bro no worries so tldr keep
it short and sweet what were your views
on Christmas
as a non-muslim and how have you been
kind of navigating around this time of
year with family that's still not Muslim
I mean man I just thought about it in
like a societal time perspective where I
was like oh this is like the holidays
can you hear me bro
yeah we can hear you now yeah I was
saying I I looked at it in a societal
lens perspective but I was like oh it's
just the holidays you know it's just
like what I've done as a kid and what
everyone in America does you know so
like what's the big deal
hmm
and then clearly you know once I came to
the slam I started kind of questioning
just the the mundane things that I would
usually do throughout the year
throughout the day like birthdays
Christmas Thanksgiving Halloween you
know Fourth of July stuff like this I
was just kind of a question of where'd
this actually come from like why why are
we even celebrating this as a holiday or
something like this and that's why I
came across uh
Christmas bro around me bro tell them
well as far as I know Christmas started
as a pagan origin
even the whole concept of like Santa and
that stuff
um I'm sure you guys have at least heard
of Krampus before
um I believe back in the day they would
say like like to their kids if you're
bad Krampus is going to come and steal
you at night and I I as far as I know
from that came the idea of a fat white
man named Santa who's gonna come in your
chimney instead of stealing you if
you're good he's going to leave you
presents or whatever so they really
dumbed it down and they combined it I
don't know where where this happened but
eventually they combined it with you
know the birthday of Jesus where Jesus
actually was not born in December at all
um nor does it make sense we're gonna be
born December
um they tied it to the birthday of Jesus
and then they added or we're gonna put
up Christmas trees and we're gonna give
gifts and all this stuff was well Jesus
did not celebrate it Jesus did not tell
people as far as not to even celebrate
his birth
um people did not he did not tell people
to give these kind of gifts on this day
or put up a tree or there's no that's
the Matrix 100 yeah there's there's no
religious uh connotation except Jesus
name is slapped on it and um maybe back
in the day they used to tell stories
about how Jesus was born
um and make like knockoff episodes like
if you saw this week like a Life of Zack
and Cody they had like a knock off
episode where like if there's something
very similar happens to the story of
Jesus now is completely let me go to
Black Friday shopping and Cyber Monday
and boxing day and get as many gifts for
a good price as possible it's become
completely capitalistic it's it's
interesting you say that because I was
completely thinking about that the other
day how it's all that was 100 planned by
people at the top of that pyramid where
it's like all right we have Christmas we
convince them it has to do with their
religion we get them to spend money they
can't afford on gifts that are priced
with 10 000 X margins and then we give
them a sale a month earlier so that they
can buy these at a discount
and we make millions and millions every
year I mean it's yeah smart on their end
100
there it is
until finally found that verse um bro
the brother just put it on there
or what
no put his number up
86 yeah this brother says the 25th of
December uh is the birthday of the Pagan
god saturnalia wow the church tied it to
that so I I think we have to obviously
fact check that but I'm sure it is a lot
deeper and you know in relation to that
as well 100 so basically there's no
really real religious connotation to it
unless you consider the paganism you
know religious connotation
um
I mean so there's something is this
brother a mother bro
I don't know I don't think this is the
right verse Man
though
no hurries no worries so my brother Ali
hater sent the Super Chat for five bucks
and then he sent the same one for 10
bucks
so we got a Reason YouTube and watch the
hairdresser of Pharaoh's daughter
fahad's spoken word it will give you an
Insight on Islam highly recommend
I'll add it to the list
um brother so I think suddenly you had a
question before we started talking about
uh Christmas about Jesus right about the
birth or him talking as a baby right
yeah I mentioned that's that's what I've
learned from you guys about Christmas so
far so
it's it's very interesting because Islam
in the Quran is not the only resource
that mentions Jesus talking as a baby
and it's not the only source that
mentions Jesus making birds out of clay
and breathing life into it
have you heard of the Gospel of Thomas
before
yes the Gospel of Thomas is something
that they don't that Christians don't
consider canonical they don't consider
authentic in a part of the Bible or part
of the religion whereas I believe
um
historians
um for example the New Testament
Scholars at the Jesus seminar and those
in relation to them they do consider it
as a you know historical record like the
other gospels because in the book that I
mentioned before the five gospels they
include Mark Matthew Luke and John and
the Gospel of Thomas and again the
gospel Thomas talks about Jesus speaking
um as a baby in the cradle and it talks
about him molding birds out of clay and
breathing into them life why is this not
something that's canonical in in
Christendom it's because it doesn't talk
about the crucifixion or the
resurrection of Jesus it doesn't mention
the crucifixion or Resurrection at all
so they say this cannot be ranked
basically
huh
no sign though a little side note yeah
they actually put it on here so the
verse had to bring it back bro the verse
it says uh these are the ones who trade
the here after for the life of this
world so the punishment will not be
reduced nor will they be helped
hmm
wow go ahead
[Laughter]
just completely rip it right there bro I
found it
um something to say or should I ask
another question no that was my only
point about Jesus as the baby and all
that the Gospel of Thomas so with stuff
like that where it's him talking as a
baby so we we've talked about this where
it's like
it's not as literal as it sounds
something like that so like Jesus
turning Water to Wine it didn't it
doesn't necessarily mean he literally
took a bottle of water shook it and then
it became wine it maybe meant like he
told people not to hoard so much and to
share and then that ends up leading to
more water for other people it's not
like something like that but then it's
in it's written in the Bible do you know
what I'm talking about I don't know if I
had this conversation with you guys but
it I said the facts it says don't
directly mean what it's like what it's
saying so it's
I see so it's like a metaphorical thing
it's not a literal thing exactly yeah I
see I see well I mean listen if that's
the case it doesn't really stand up for
Christians or Christianity because all
these proofs that Jesus is God that he
did these Miracles go out the window and
he's no longer a god from their
estimation even though I don't think
that's a strong argument to begin with
um they're just making it worse for
themselves when they remove that you
know that miraculous aspect
huh yeah that's a good point yeah is
there anything like that with Islam
where it's it's very up for is there
much that's up for interpretation or
where you need to look at it from a
different lens or is it mostly like
exactly what the book says it depends on
what you're talking about if you're
talking about versus like for example
the scientific things I mentioned those
have different interpretations and stuff
when it comes to like Miracles I don't
think there's any Muslim or scholar on
the or scholar of Quran on the face of
the Earth that will take for example
um Moses splitting the sea and say oh
that's metaphorical because Allah
describes you know Musa did this and
then split the ocean open the children
of Israel walked through it and then
that same ocean crushed the
um the Pharaoh and his people basically
you know destroying their enemies I
don't see how that could be metaphorical
so I don't think the any Miracle that's
mentioned is metaphorical and it would
completely undermine the purpose of a
miracle uh imagine imagine you know
someone comes to you and said oh my God
Romney did this phenomenal thing this
huge Miracle you know he he made a chair
from nothing and you're like oh my god
really and they're like it's a metaphor
bro it's a metaphor you know he sat down
on the floor you know
that's funny yeah bro you had a question
about the Mirage the night Journey a lot
of uh Subs are asking about that
then what was it
I think uh so a lot of Subs are saying
that you had a question about the night
journey in Islam
no I think that's just someone telling
him to ask about that people say some
crazy stuff in um in DMs I saw someone I
I itched my eye and someone said was he
given the finger
it's like bro it's itching my eyes could
you read this up yeah this is a really
good point so
um Hamza says about Jesus peace be upon
him talking as a baby you have to
remember that in that time the Jews um
basically they had the death penalty for
anyone who committed adultery and that's
why Allah made Jesus basically speak as
a baby to defend her and that's what's
narrated in the Quran they went to Maria
you know Miriam Mary peace be upon her
and said how could he do such a
atrocious thing you know your father was
not a a bad person and your mother was a
chaste woman you know why would you do
such a horrible thing and it says uh
that he she pointed to him and they were
like how am I going to talk to a baby
and then Jesus spoke and said uh about
the law you know I'm a servant of God he
is giving me the scripture and so on and
so forth
um because it's meant to defend her and
that's a good question if this story in
terms of Christianity was was true that
Jesus came from a virgin birth why
didn't they Stone her because if Jesus
is the baby he doesn't talk he doesn't
do Miracles how can she prove that this
was a miracle and it was Immaculate
Conception why why didn't they just
Stone her for it you know what would be
the answer for that
which maybe there is one I don't know
about a Christianity but for me that
that doesn't make sense the Jews would
have punished her for that because they
they saw his adultery for sure
because also bro there's this question
that I wanted to highlight and get us to
answer but someone asked is Allah and
the Christian God the same person I.E
like the father
um the father I would say yes because
this is the god that Jesus worshiped
from you know obviously in our
estimation and the god that Jesus told
everybody to worship
um but when you look at the Trinity
father son Holy Spirit three persons one
God that's that's not Islamic uh Allah
says in the Quran do not say three don't
say three don't say
and don't say that God has a son either
so this this really does bring me to beg
the question Sonny
where are you in terms of your belief
when you imagine God do you believe in
like one God do you believe in the
Trinity do you believe in polytheism
like where do you stand just unfiltered
when you just mentioned the Trinity
again it kind of had me thinking so like
if God with like Christianity's view if
what is like the difference between God
and then like the holy spirit because
like in my mind I see that as like kind
of the same thing
um I don't know I it's hard to answer
because like I'm I I believe you guys
can't even fully answer like how you
visualize Allah right like you can't
give him human characteristics or
anything like that it's almost like
the spirit or not a spirit but something
that's everywhere and with you correct
so the term saying God is everywhere you
have to well like islamically you have
to be very careful because we don't
believe that God is literally everywhere
but we see he he we know that he sees
everything he's everything he's aware of
everything so in that sense you know he
knows everything everywhere and he's
aware of everything everywhere but he's
not you know like physically or
literally everywhere in that sense so we
don't use that kind of praying
islamically to be you know as safe as
possible
huh
but yeah I mean it's it's it's probably
one of the hardest questions to give
like a definitive answer on is like how
do you see God when you don't align with
one specific religion you know what I
mean like that's like making up your own
religion if you're just gonna give a a
brand new answer
um it's it's tough to to say exactly
what I visualize but when I do I would
say it's like I told you
um more of
I guess an energy kind of thing where
it's
it's like a loving force that you have
to you know abide by and do good for
like it's
it's the same thing with um
I don't know I just feel like I'm
butchering it but like if you if you
really want to lose
what's up when you say it's particles no
I I that's the thing like I wouldn't
even say it's particles
no no no he busted my chops but like
it's something like you obviously can't
see like there's like a I think that you
know even in like the lens of an animal
for example like he can hear
or see stuff that a human can't see like
we already have different perspectives
on everything around us so that almost
shows that there's like different
energies and levels of everything that
we perceive
so if that's just like there's
differences in what we see around us
between me and like my dog for example
that shows that there's so many
different layers that neither of us can
even like truly visualize does that kind
of make sense
like there's so much more than what you
just see with the naked eye the 100 the
the more the more you learn the more you
realize you don't know they call it the
Kruger effect
um and I think that's a good example of
that but one thing about God is since
you cannot see God or directly speak
with God you you you really can't know
anything about God except that which he
tells you there are some things you can
deduce about God uh for example
if everything that exists depends on
something else
right then nothing would exist because
the first thing that exists exactly
depends on something else yeah so we
thought the infinite regression doesn't
make that so what you conclude is that
there's something that doesn't depend on
something else it's independent
necessary and always existed you know
that's something you can deduce about
God and that's a part of the what they
call the contingency argument for uh for
something that's necessary like for
basically just God
um but when it comes to you know God is
all loving or or loving or has you know
loves in any way or
you know God has Mercy or God created
heaven and hell and all these things you
can't really prove any of that stuff
unless God himself gives you a religion
and a prophet that proves it for you and
I think that's why Islam is so powerful
because we don't say that oh Islam is
true because you're going to die and
wake up on the day of judgment no no we
say You're Gonna you you should know
that you're gonna die and become the day
of judgment because Islam I could prove
it's true using this and this and this
evidence so we prove Islam in internally
and externally and once we do that we
say now that you know slams the truth
and you have evidence you should know
that angels exist Heaven and Hell exist
you will be held accountable for your
actions and these are the things that
God wants you to do
about the Trinity we don't believe in
you know co-equal co-eternal Partners we
believe God is one very simple like Army
mentioned in the last episode with your
mom we believe you know the son who is
Jesus Christ is not even the son right
it's just a human being a prophet of
Allah and we believe the Holy Spirit to
be a creation of Allah as well which is
just the angel Gabriel right the
Archangel that gives you know Revelation
to prophets not anything as a part of
God or one with God
hmm I definitely do have to say though
it makes a lot more sense to me than the
Holy Trinity like if I'm just being
honest like having one one God like that
in my mind does just add up more and you
you want to be too loud you know your
family's right there yeah you know
you know don't worry you're not you're
definitely not the only one bro that's I
think literally everyone including
Christians whether they want to admit it
or not and and totality
um at the end of the day the idea of one
God
is a lot simpler and makes more sense in
a three-in-one God that's co-equal
co-eternal where Jesus was given birth
to and died and didn't know everything
but he's God who's all-knowing at the
end of the day it's it's never going to
make as much sense as what the Jews and
the Muslims believe yeah and there's a
lot of um a lot of people out there that
will try to give metaphors as to how the
Trinity is correct and how it works but
these are just metaphors but then when
you actually take the real thing the
actual Trinity and you reply logically
like remember God gave us intellect
God gave us logic why he gave us this
logic so that we could reason so that we
could reflect so that we could see the
signs and Ponder on them like we have
limited into like for a reason
because if it was unlimited then we
would be at the same level that God is
and that's there'd be no point at this
point right but if
I mean again you're thinking to yourself
and it's like oh this doesn't make sense
and like I had a friend back in the day
where I told him about this and then he
tried to give me the metaphor that the
Trinity was like uh water
that when it freezes it's still water
but then it can melt and turn back into
water and then you can um evaporate and
be yes exactly and then that's still
water in essence I'm like bro yeah okay
the example makes sense but now like
think about it logically think about it
rationally think about the actual thing
that you're reading in this book and
just apply your own logic to it and like
your own logic will fail to actually
comprehend it because again like it's
it's it's not it was it was something
that was man-made another thing though
is like is God meant to be like fully
understood you know what I mean because
there's so much like even with time like
technically time goes back infinitely
and goes forward infinitely like we
don't even know what like what we don't
even know what time is and that's what
we go by like that's the most important
metric of life you know what I mean so
if you think of something like that it's
like are you really meant to fully
understand God so it's like I almost
understand Christians too because it's
like it's such a complex topic that
there's already so much you know and not
like missing pieces but like mystery in
a sense to it yeah where it's like
believing something like the Trinity is
like it's it's understandable but I I
would agree that like one God makes more
sense in my mind you know what I'm
saying yeah yeah yeah yeah it's
understandable
but it's not acceptable and I like I'll
be the one to say that just because I
was in it myself I've experienced it
myself and again you use your own logic
you will come to the you will come to
the answer like no this is not it and it
goes back to what Rami had said you know
like
we can deduce certain things and come to
a point where we can say oh this is
something of God this is what God might
be or no others we don't even know what
God is but look there's something
where you me and everything else in this
world comes from
we can deduce that from just looking
around and using our internet we can
deduce that there's an origin that we
all stem from right or that we we were
created from 100 and then what you said
is like God is not meant to be fully
fully understood because this this is
true you know we're not really gonna
understand everything about the Creator
we only understand what the creator has
given to us to understand again we have
limited intellect for a reason and if we
if we were to understand everything 100
if we were to say ah yeah God's real 100
percent
it will kind of will kind of ruin the
whole point of uh being tested
yeah exactly you there wouldn't be no
there would be no test at this point no
it wouldn't be yeah I I couldn't agree
more with that that that totally makes
sense
um and you've you've never been atheist
though have you
um no not that I could think of I've
never been like no like if I do bad like
it is what it is you know like
the sun's coming like I I don't know
like I I haven't really fawned down that
trap too much to be honest
with this whole world around us
everything was created by chance
yeah I I just I don't believe that at
all to be honest like and it kind of
always goes back to the time thing for
me like the biggest thing that hit for
me when I went to Catholic School in
high school was like the first movement
like what what made the first movement
you know like what happened first and um
when you really think about that it's
it's kind of impossible I feel like it
seems almost like an impossible scenario
for there to be no God you know
like how how could everything just just
come from from come from nothing like
even the Big Bang is a theory it's
called The Big Bang Theory and people
don't even talk about that it's it's
it's recognized as fact black holes you
can't even technically see a black hole
it's a it's about black holes in itself
are theories because they capture light
but nobody even knows that it's just
like black holes and the big bang and
it's like well particles got so small
they explain I don't know like that like
religion and a god makes more sense than
that stuff to me
yeah absolutely absolutely and um I
think at the end of the day it always
will to everyone even even if you even
if you believe in the Big Bang which is
not a problem you know islamically
religiously think uh speaking it's what
happened before the Big Bang what caused
the Big Bang what caused the thing that
caused the big bang you know you can
always go back infinitely
um and that would be a fallacy so you
have to start at one place
um that's my man yeah I'm here I don't
know what's up with my mic I think it's
a video yeah
for a bit
one second I'm trying to fix it
um okay just while you fix it we got a
super chat um Taco verse says Sonny
check out Dear Mom by talk Islam it will
make your mom smile it's made by the
same guy who made the meaning of life
Muslim spoken word
oh nice yeah and then uh Mo sent the
Super Chat saying they're teaching kids
to idolize something other than Allah
and they believe that they can get gifts
without worship without the worship of
Allah therefore think of Santa as
shaytan or as Satan huh can I join right
back I think I I have to leave real
quick yeah for sure two seconds no
worries we should also bring the um the
brothers to take a shahada
and and speaking of Brothers this Super
Chat is actually from a brother by the
name of Dom who took a shot with us so
head over to our Channel page
if you missed that not young dumb a
little bit older though
and he has subjected to you all that is
in the heavens and all that is in the
earth it is all as a favor and kindness
from him verily in it are signs for
people who think deeply oh my God this
thing is
that's hold up
there we go
my camera's too far so I have to like
hold something where my face is to match
it it's a smart trick man it's a good
trick
um Sunny have you ever visited a mosque
no I've never
all right has that that kind of leads me
to another one of my questions has there
ever been any like corruption in Islam
so I know looking into like Christianity
like at my high school actually it was
one of the high schools where like the
priests were like touching kids and
stuff back in the day crazy stuff and
I've seen like if you look back like a
few hundred years like the Catholic
Church sold passes to get into heaven
like crazy stuff used to happen so I
don't know much about Islam though
there's no corruption in Islam itself
but with Muslims of course
yeah
and I would say I would say definitely
not to the extent that um uh you know
like the Catholic church or the Orthodox
church has taken it in the past you know
like in the Dark Ages uh in Europe it
was nothing close to that and if you
want to look at Islam you know the
process he said basically the best of
people are my generation and then the
generation to come after that then the
generation come after that so if you
want to look at like the best Muslims
you look at the first three generations
of the Prophet peace be upon him when
you look at like um
when he went and he conquered places he
conquered you know basically up to the
like borders of China you didn't have
forced conversions you didn't have you
know killing of innocent people or
anything crazy like that you you find
that for example when they conquered
horasan which is I think a place like
basically around like the Persian area
um he didn't they didn't make anyone
accept Islam but over time basically
everyone saw their beauty in Islam and
they accepted it on their own volition
and this is in the historical records
you know you can read about it so you
will find Muslims in history that did
tremendously horrible things 100
even some Muslim leaders in cases
um but you'll also also find the Muslims
that follow the book end up doing the
best things
um and one good example is there is a
Muslim ruler that was persecuting Jews
so what did the Jews do and one Jew in
particular who wrote about it I'll find
his name later he migrated to another
Muslim ruler and that Muslim ruler took
care of him and even made him like I
think a governor or or a general of some
sort
so so where does like Muslim extremists
come into the picture because like
that's where like America it's always
like a weird thing to talk about but
because that's how Americans view it as
you know for a whole and I think a lot
of that has to do with like 9 11 and
stuff like that
um but like where like what do those
people believe like are they do they
identify as Muslims but they're just
crazy or like
so
by the way before you answer it I was
going to say
I sent the link to the subscriber that
wants to take a shot by the way
okay so uh well invite him inshallah
once he wants he jumps on yeah before
you go around me I was talking to this
with my mom today bro
and the thing is man
everywhere in this world there are
people who are extremists
I mean there are people who take things
out of context
um usually it has to do with you know
once you get in the extremist mentality
you end up living in a bubble right you
you have a you you're delusional for
like a bit of words you see things for
how you want to see them versus how they
actually are
you know and
the example that I can give to you is in
Christianity you had this group of
people known as the KKK
oh yeah no I'm not like there's I 100
see extremists and Corruption everywhere
and even with like an audience like
let's say I have a hundred thousand
people watching if 300 of those people
go and do some crazy stuff because of my
video it's not my fault like that's
point three percent of people listening
to what I say and then going and doing
something based off of it and this
politics always does this with each side
like they point at the other sides
extremists so like the left their
propaganda is focused around pushing
like the far right people like whatever
they say like black X should be in their
own schools like all the crazy stuff
they push that and then the right push
what the like the crazy stuff the left
does like you know the transgenders
playing men's women's sports and all
that and then everyone just gets their
own skewed point of views and hate each
other you know and I mean if if we go to
the question you say you know what's
going on these people's minds especially
Muslims that are going on with this
um listen I can't I can't speak for them
because I'm not there I I don't
experience that I don't have that
mentality or anything like that I don't
know any one person that has that
mentality but just subjectively speaking
I could
come to a theory and my theory is that
these people they lack guidance
and when they lack guidance they have
that fitra they have the internal State
the belief that they want you know they
want to believe in the Creator they want
to do things right and be righteous and
then what ends up happening is there
comes someone someone comes and
basically
I was I was going to say something real
bad but they come and they just mess
everything up and what they do is um
they're very passionate in the way of
speaking and when someone is looking for
guidance and someone comes along and
they're very passionate in the way that
they speak
this person that is looking for guidance
will be very
impressionable I guess I think that's a
word impressionable right impressionable
they're gonna look at this person and
like ah
he knows what he's talking about he
knows what he's doing he knows where to
go let's take on what he's saying here
it's kind of like we look back in time
and we look at you know people like
Hitler we look at people like Stalin we
look at other leaders or Genghis Khan
things like this we look at conkers
leaders like bro
these are people that were very
passionate and they they were very
articulate they knew how to
say and do certain things
that made people follow them so again I
just think it's just misguidance but
then again like God knows best I truly I
can't say what the truth is here yeah so
you answered my question then it's just
extremists that the 99.9 of the religion
don't identify with same as any other
group but then that's what gets
portrayed as the majority which is
pretty crazy so yeah exactly yeah I also
want to add to the discussion a bit
because even when you look at you know a
lot of these people their reason is not
a stem even if they say it is you know
the reason is not Islamic um if you look
at like you know Bin Laden he said that
he's doing what he's doing and he did
what he did basically because America
attacked Afghan and then and you know
they did their Jihad against these
people and he says they're the biggest
tyrants they're the biggest Crooks you
know and a lot of these people like for
example the Isis members when they're
captured and like interrogated and asked
why did you join they say because um
because I was poor they offered me money
they offered me women they offer me
whatever it's only 24 self-gain and for
political reasons in our religion 100
not religion because if they were to
read the Quran the same verses they
quote that you know unalive this person
that person they can look before or
after and it gives context for example
in chapter eight it says if they uh
incline towards peace it doesn't say if
they surrender if they even incline
towards peace then also incline towards
peace because we don't want to go and
like you know on people and attack
people that's not something that's
Islamic so you know all these people
it's it's 100 because America has
destabilized the Middle East has left
them with no political authorities and
when that happens you have the rise of a
bunch of different groups that want to
grab that Authority and want to be on
top whether they think they're right and
and what they're doing or not it's
something that's 100 political and not
following Islamic guidelines at all
huh
yeah that makes that makes perfect sense
and that that does really clear that up
for me
that's good that's good so this is the
last Super Chat I believe before we
bring on the subscriber
Salam what do you hope to gain from this
conversation do you see yourself as a
Muslim
um
I mean I hope to just keep learning to
be quite honest
um I don't see myself as a Muslim now
obviously
um but I also don't see myself as a
Christian now like I I've explained what
I believe as much as I could and you
know I'm in the process of reading the
Quran and doing more research so I'm
kind of just going to keep going about
it and if I find it's you know the truth
and it's what I want to go with then you
know I'll of course go with it but um at
the moment you know I you know I'm just
still learning I think everyone goes
through their learning process I think
one of you guys said it took it took you
a few years from first really learning
about it before you actually converted
I like that all right conversions
Ronnie bro we got sunny and Ronnie
Ronnie
yeah Romney Ronnie
all right welcome my man welcome thank
you thank you
thank you of course of course so
what before we actually maybe let's
let's do the shahada first and then
we'll ask him about his journey and
stuff are you down for that one
all right let's get the most important
thing out of the way so I'm gonna share
my screen just like I did for the uh our
last brother that accepted Islam can you
guys see my screen uh yeah yes okay
firstly Ronnie I want to ask just to
make sure that you have your your
beliefs islamically in line before we do
the shahada do you believe that there's
only one god-worthy of worship and he
has no Partners or Associates yes
perfect do you believe in the Angels
yeah do you believe in the prophets and
Messengers that God sent yes do you
believe in the Revelation that God has
sent with these prophets like the Torah
like the gospel like the Quran yes
perfect do you believe in destiny that
God has for all of us a Divine decree
that he has yes and lastly do you
believe in the day of judgment yes
perfect so now all you're going to do is
repeat after me let's bring the um the
shahada back on the screen yes so you're
going to repeat after me in Arabic and
then you're you're going to repeat after
me in English Okay you ready yeah ilaha
illallah
and now you're going to repeat after me
in English I bear witness I bear witness
that there is none worthy of worship
except Allah that there's none worthy of
worship except Allah and I bear witness
and I bear with goodness that the
prophet Muhammad that the prophet
the prophet is the final messenger of
God is defined a messenger of that and
the final prophet of God and the final
prophet of God
welcome to Islam our brother Ronnie your
name is
[Laughter]
solely bro we want to we want to know
about your story man yeah tell us a bit
about your journey and where you were
introduced
well I would say it all started like
maybe like two years ago
when I got I got really sick
I got a stomach a stomach illness which
I still have today which we don't really
we don't know what it is pretty much wow
yeah and you know like
I would say like that that like pushed
me into like a depression really
and I kind of started um
I went towards like you know substance
abuse smoking weed a lot I look young
but I'm 20.
so so I was doing that a lot and then I
would say about like
three months ago I started just like
looking more into religion
and you know I'm actually a born
Catholic but like it was never like it
was never pushed upon me or my family or
like my brothers or sisters
it was never pushed on us
so when I started doing my research I I
was really open-minded I didn't really
know anything about any religion
and to me Islam just automatically
instantly just made the most just in the
sense to me I guess you could say
yeah and like I had a lot of trouble
stop stopping like I could I I would
smoke a lot really and
and it was hard for me to stop and but
once I accepted the like like I was once
I realized that Islam is the truth I'm I
went cold turkey like it was nothing wow
wow that is bad how long have you been
feeling that way bro that Islam is the
truth
um I would say it was probably about a
month and a half ago when I when I
really really realized that and even
when that happened you know because of
like my stomach sickness it's really
hard for me to get a job like a normal
job because I I just struggle with a lot
of like pains and and I'm stuck in the
restroom a lot to a whole lot of stuff
and whoa whoa whoa whoa hold up hold up
bro
are you are you gluten intolerant or
lactose intolerant no
how do you know
uh I've gotten a lot of tests done
interesting bro have you done like an
Elimination Diet just to see like
if there's any kind of food that's
actually reacting in your system yeah I
I we we've tried that it's no Foods
really we we think it's um I don't know
I don't know how much you guys know
about water but we think it's abs and
there's no like real test for that
really they said no a doctor told me so
it's kind of like a long process of
elimination so I've gotten a colonoscopy
and got an um
ultrasound of a bunch of stuff
bro I swear I swear to God bro
when I was in ninth grade I had to go to
the doctors and get all these tests done
and had a colonoscopy as well because I
was having issues with my stomach as
well and
um they diagnosed me with the same thing
IBS and
um supposedly that that's just basically
them saying look we have no idea what
the hell is going on yeah exactly but
we're gonna we're gonna diagnose you
with something here so you don't think
that we don't have any idea what we're
doing
um I mean for me bro I found out that I
was actually lactose intolerant I was
not really gluten intolerant but I'm
intolerant to eggs I can't eat eggs
um I find that my body does best if I
just eat meat and fruits I don't know if
you've ever tried that maybe worth a try
I know please please try it I will
honestly the when you guys showed the
video of the halami that was amazing and
I was like seeing like the calmness and
like how like and Ethan and Romney
talking about like the blood like I'm
more of the blood going out it just
seems a lot cleaner like so much
I have I I basically have a friend who
his uh his wife is a Reaver and
subhanallah she used to be a vegan bro
never have any me you know meat just
always gives her digestive issues and
then after accepting Islam I think she
slowly started having like fish and then
now she has like you know chicken and
and beef you know halal meat and no
digestive issues bro subhanallah wow
yeah there's a difference too man with
halal meat versus like conventional meat
uh Sunnyvale I remember you were talking
about like the whole energy thing and
and how like
uh you kind of know like that there's
something there there's something
different like when a dog can experience
things that we don't experience and all
that and then when we were talking about
like slaughtering and how like if you
kill an animal and it has a lot of
cortisol running through his body what
ends up happening is it changes
energetically right it goes from a let's
say normal or positive vibration so to
speak and then it goes to a negative
vibration because it has all the stress
hormone that stress hormone is going to
basically result in a negative frequency
and when you eat this from like you
taste that you can taste it in the
conventional meat versus Halal me and
then there's this whole saying in
science which is basically the energy
cannot be created
only be transferred so if that's true
then that means that if an animal dies
in a negative State then that means we
consume that and then we also take on
that negative State and I mean look I'll
let everyone just kind of like be their
own test subjects and see for themselves
when they try it out I do that
um diet actually like a lot of meat and
fruit really yeah how you like olive oil
yeah it's it's I'm I'm I'm not like
super super strict about it but I have
like a few steaks a day for the most
part I drink raw milk another thing you
said about lactose intolerance is a lot
of the time you're intolerant to like
the fake crab milk with a bunch of
hormones and stuff in it and not like
actually raw milk and like I my health
guy um I have like a personal health
coach and he said there's been tons of
lactose intolerant people who then
switch to you know raw organic milk
which you can't even get at stores you
have to order it as like pet food
because it's not like supposed to be
drank it's all part of the Matrix scam
but then they're totally fine when
you're drinking like just natural milk
not with a bunch of chemicals and stuff
it's crazy
I gotta try some of this I I don't want
to talk too much because I know this is
a special moment but I went through I
went through something too like that not
with my stomach but with my skin and the
thing was cutting out GMO foods and a
lot of Highly processed stuff that was
the biggest thing for me and making sure
I switched to like a more meat based
diet and more organic food
um completely changed it they they could
even like I had my whole skin was red
from head to toe I I couldn't sleep I
was so itchy it was horrible and no
doctor knew what it was and in a matter
of days of switching to healthier food I
was all good that's all I got to say
though I don't wanna
ramble someone suggested Ronnie pick up
the book medical medium
but Ronnie bro I got some questions for
you if Anna's done with all the medical
diagnosis stuff uh which I'm down to
pick that up later too
um but on your journey bro did you have
any doubts when you kind of realized
that you know what Islam is the truth a
lot of brothers and sisters they have
they have some doubts with family you
know other brothers and sisters they
have dealt with themselves or it could
be even with desires bro because a lot
of them are like you know what I really
want to smoke this one thing or drink
this one thing or go to this one place
but now I can no longer do that as a
Muslim so they would rather basically
confuse themselves into delusion into
that Islam is not real instead of just
accept that maybe I can't do this one
thing anymore
I feel they're what you're talking about
how they want to do certain things I'm
always someone who wanted uh my whole
left arm tattooed
and and stuff like that but like I think
I never had really doubts like that
because once I like really started
looking into it
and just seeing like you know one of the
biggest things for me is how how in
Islam they tell you to seek knowledge
and seek everything
and so to me that's like it it's just
amazing and it just like really opened
my eyes so now like I couldn't care less
about these things at all like
well it's I don't know no that's
beautifully said actually that kind of
um
that kind of um touches on one question
I have for you which is I think Sunny is
going down a very similar path where he
is looking for the truth and he's
looking for what is true and there's
actually one comment earlier about this
do you have any advice or any general
thoughts since you've been down this
path already
um like advice on what like like seeking
the truth
um and uh maybe maybe from an assigned
perspective maybe not it's completely up
to you because it's your journey but uh
advice on going down this path and
looking for the truth from God
I mean I would say just like I've heard
a lot of people say this but like really
just I feel like I'm thankful like I was
born Catholic but you know it was like
I've never really been religious I was
never pushed on me so I was very
unbiased
and to support to me there was I've
always like believed in there was a God
and that and that was like the extent so
like I just like the Islam just called
me the most because you know the one God
everything the Christianity to me always
was like a little
a little far out there with the Trinity
and especially Catholicism with like the
donations and everything
so yeah I would say just look at it from
an unbiased perspective really and just
don't yeah that's pretty much it
honestly I really don't know the baskets
they bring around
two percent of you are about to say bro
I was just about to say I remember they
used to shove that basket down your
throat no no I don't have
for real that's that's funny Ronnie
where are you from by the way uh I mean
I'm originally from Los Angeles and uh
now so like California now I live in
Washington state I moved here about
like three four years ago now oh nice
yeah so you know the West not not the
greatest place
I wanted to move California initially
until I got older and realized how left
it is I didn't want to leave and once I
left and I never want to go back never
yeah screw that dude
all right guys uh do you any of you guys
around me I know or even Sunny bro Sunny
do you have any questions for Ronnie
anything else that you know because I'm
sure you know he was exactly where you
might be not too long ago in his journey
yeah so um where did you like kind of
find Islam like I was it through more of
YouTube or do you have Muslim
um friends I have I don't I know one
Muslim and he's like a pretty
like I don't want to say but he's not a
great representation of being a Muslim
so yeah I would say I really just found
it through like just like I was just
curious in religion in general so I kind
of just started learning about all the
religions and Islam just to me drew the
most and you know videos for sure like
is where I really learn the most you
know I've actually seen your your videos
with your mom react which I like because
you know your mom reminds you of my mom
a lot actually
so I wrote like yeah just videos and
just learning about all different types
of religions and seeing what called me
huh that's awesome man
wow
um I can't really think of any other
questions if you guys don't mind yeah
yeah
I just like um
you guys you had a podcast and we're
talking uh I think his name was Gabriel
and but uh if I had mentioned that when
you seek knowledge you should seek it in
the right places and I just wanted to
know like what you think are like the
right places to to seek this knowledge
and the wrong places
around me please
yeah so first and foremost the best
place would be the um the Quran do you
have a copy by the way no I was actually
gonna ask about that too because there's
so many different translations for the
English like I just don't know which
ones okay we're gonna make a we're gonna
make an Instagram group chat bro as soon
as we're done like we did with brother
Sheed who took a shot of the last week
and we'll send you a couple resources
there just that we do with some of the
other brothers and sisters such as um
you know resources on how to pray and
basics of that and in that if you want
you can send us your address and we'd
love to send you one
of course of course you're our brother
man you're our brother in Islam
alhamdulillah so any other questions
uh I actually like wrote like two or
three down real quick let me see let's
go for it
oh yeah so one question I had is about
the fast and so you know for someone
like me like I am sick so like I I I
can't really gain weight in general
like I actually lost like 30 pounds in
two weeks when I first got sick and so
like it like I feel like it's kind of
dangerous for me not to eat sometimes
yeah
that's a great question so islamically
um every rule every general rule has its
exceptions right
um and this is a great exception of it
if a person The Scholar say if a
person's health is at risk or they could
die as a result of fasting then that
person is not obligated to Fast Very
similarly when you look at we've
discussed this earlier you know pork is
Haram to eat but at the same time if
you're dying and there's nothing to eat
except pork then now it's actually an
obligation for you to eat that pork to
continue to survive
so likewise this is an exception when a
you know perhaps a woman who's pregnant
she and the baby might be at stake um or
someone in your case they might be at
stake some the scholars say that in in
some of these cases the person's not
obligated to fast
and yo if you didn't mind I actually
wanted to read a Quran verse bro that
goes into that very in depth and it's in
a chapter two Surah al-baqarah in verse
183 so it says o Believers fasting is
prescribed for you as it was for those
before you so perhaps you will become
mindful of God and then in the 184th
verse Allah says fast a prescribed
number of days but whoever of you is ill
or on a journey then let them fast an
equal number of days after Ramadan but
for those who can only fast with extreme
difficulty compensation can be made by
feeding a needy person
for every day that is not fasted but
whoever volunteers to give more is
better for them and then this needy
person in the sub note basically says
this in in the case of old age or
chronic disease so in your case
so I should like put it forward and try
to feed someone in need pretty much yeah
you could do that or we can we can hit
up some people of knowledge in our
Circle that might you know be able to
answer that a little bit more
professionally
oh and then another question I had like
you know I I really want to try halami
you know I I really want to want to eat
it but like how do I go about finding a
place around like me that South salami
head out of meat it's gonna put me on
Google bro if you put Google just on
Google uh Halal Supermarket or halal
meat near me and you should be able to
find a place like bro I was looking for
a place when my mom had moved out to
where she lives now I can't see it
obviously you know you can't believe my
location like this but I didn't I didn't
know there was one like right here next
to me like literally less than two
minutes away from me wow yeah yeah so
you'll never know until you put it on
Google and find out hmm
yeah you could also go to a mosque
there's a lot of Muslims there they will
know the in and outs they'll know the
best uh places inshallah to get for them
all right so floor is still open to you
and sunny if either of you guys have
questions and also I guess to the
comments as well if you guys if the
viewers have questions
inshallah so I'll just put up the super
chats but in the meantime uh just a
quick reminder to Sunny take your time
bro until the next stream do a little
bit more research and your mom is
welcome to do so herself like we talked
about in the previous stream and to all
the viewers guys stay tuned for March
2023 one of the biggest guests if not
the biggest guest that we've had so far
this is going to be a really hype
in-person podcast we're going somewhere
overseas I'll leave it at that
Insha'Allah but here's the first Super
Chat AWS writes I always love listening
to these conversations much respect to
this channel for all the knowledge it's
spreading lots of love and respect from
Kuwait may Allah bless you and accept it
from us
actually I have a question for you
Ronnie why did you want to get a full
sleeve tattoo
you know I really and that's another
thing I really don't even know it was
just like something I wanted to tell a
little I was always like you know you
see it and like thankfully I I mean I
think clearly I I have one small one but
I'm but like I was I had like plans to
get the whole thing like really soon and
then like I'm glad I did I really did it
now honestly yeah
Bros yeah yeah so we're altering
altering the uh creation of Allah so
tattoo in essence you're altering the
creation
but also depends on what you're doing to
alter so if you're trying to restore the
creation of Allah such as you know
basically some types of surgery on the
body that basically does alter it but it
kind of brings it back to what it should
be Prosthetics and stuff like that it's
obviously a different case than let's
say for a sister that just wants a
bigger behind that's not permissible
yeah yeah for sure that's crazy man
I usually think the same thing about
that
what's up bro oh no like earlier I was
saying um you know it was hard for me to
get a job but
literally like I accepted Islam like
that thought was the truth
and like crazy like I got like probably
the best job opportunity I could have
ever got like two weeks ago or like a
week ago wow sometimes yeah and it was
just like I was like it's like amazing
to me it was beautiful
that is beautiful
100 uh Sunny do you have any questions
for us my man
um I have a few more but I have to run
soon my mom's begging me to to film some
videos last time but you should just
give us one last question bro one last
question
yes please what all right because I
don't want to go down a whole rabbit
hole with um you know the 7-Eleven one
um what's the what's the line between
standing up for what you believe in and
fighting hate with love so I think we
kind of touched upon this last time
where Tates and I'm sorry to bring up
Tate a lot but
um one of the big things he said was
like how Christian Christians will say
or allow people to say God is gay you
know Jesus is gay and they won't do
anything about it but Muslims
um that wouldn't slide so what's the
difference if someone's saying something
like that
um like do you like do you go after that
with love and to try to teach them
um because the way he kind of said it
was like there's serious repercussions
from that from Muslims
you kind of understand what I'm saying
yeah 100 so this is a very interesting
topic because a lot of people talk about
it like being a positive note for
Muslims
um you will always have the Muslims that
you know turn to violence and to do um
certain things and certain actions
um other times Allah God himself would
just deal with these people like the guy
um I forget where he was he might be in
Denmark he was a he was burning the
Quran and all this stuff and then his
car just happened to Tumble over killing
him and the bodyguards that are with him
um Islam doesn't especially like we're
living in a non-muslim country in these
these lands Islam doesn't allow us to
actually go and retaliate against
someone unless they're physically
attacking us you know then we can defend
ourselves and fight them back and so on
and so forth but usually for these
people we we don't always respond with
love I think that's a very Christian
thing in some cases we will depending on
the person but we respond with what is
reasonable so if someone is for example
going in the streets and saying
something like oh all Muslims are are
teas and they do extreme things and all
this stuff then we can humiliate them by
saying what about your own country what
about about you know America when they
there's currently still you know doing
things in places like Syria and other
places what about you guys why are you
guys actually you've caused the most
destruction the most innocent lives lost
that we can humiliate them publicly so
they uh don't speak on Islam again
interesting
yeah that makes sense going at it with a
logical point of view rather than just
hugs and kisses Non-Stop
yeah Romy why don't you tell them what
happens if someone in the society
actually does start saying something
like
if they were gay or something like this
because I think this is like this is no
this is well this is something that like
many people have a misconception on and
they think that oh just because someone
comes out as this or whatever they're
going to be basically lashed to death or
something why don't you explain exactly
how like the process goes so you can
kind of you know bring some clarity into
this picture and yo just a reminder we
should mind the specific terms that we
say bro because we're on YouTube yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah of course of course
um well are you talking about like an
Islamic Society or in this Society
and Okay so
in Islam we have this thing known as
Sharia
right
speak about what happens with that
well I mean islamically speaking Sharia
doesn't differentiate a gay person from
a straight person that's something only
the West does or you are homosexual you
are heterosexual you are a lesbian you
are trans you are this you are that you
identify as a freaking wolf yeah doesn't
have anything like that
um you know Islam has we have men we
have women and uh men will have certain
obligations that women won't like uh you
know earning providing for the family
going to war and all that stuff and
there's a differentiation there but
there's no differentiation between a gay
person a straight person
um it is Haram to act upon those desires
you know if you if you are a gay person
and you
um you know do sleep with another man
that is something that's Haram but it's
very difficult for a punishment to
actually be enacted because for
something like that to happen
we would have to have four male
witnesses that actually see the pen go
on the ink and all this stuff that's
very hard to achieve but possible enough
that it would deter a person from
wanting from wanting to do it and
somebody even say that this the one of
the biggest purpose of this is to stop
people and prevent them from doing it in
public because if it happens in public
whether it's between man and a man woman
a woman or a man and a woman right if
they do in public then everyone will see
it and they will be taken basically to
account for that and they'll be given a
certain punishment so
islamically speaking there's no
differentiation and it's the same case
if a man married or unmarried commits
adultery with a woman or a woman commits
adultery with a man there's a punishment
for all these things because we don't
have the same ideology we don't have the
same basic you know we want to be free
and totally free even though lots of
fallacy that the West has we have well
God gives us laws and we obey God and
that is our you know basically the
divine revelation for the rules that we
have so it's like literally a completely
different society that you cannot
compare using Western values and Views
and and all that stuff that's why the
condemnation of Qatar makes literally no
sense because you're condemning them
based on a criteria that you made
imagine I come to you and I'm like I
have a criteria for a man you have to be
six foot nine you have to be either
African or Asian you have to have hair
down to your ears and you have to be
good at soccer and basketball
and then I come to everyone here and I'm
like you guys all suck because you don't
meet the criteria I made that's exactly
what the West does when it comes to
Muslims
it's fallacious
so I know I went on a lot but I hope
that answers the question what do you
what do you say to this this uh clown or
maybe you know maybe they're just
misinformed me I'll look at them but
someone writes I think it's a sheep but
in Islam you're either a man or an
object
well first and foremost yeah that's
programming yeah yeah 100 if if you want
to make a claim you have to provide
evidence so if you want to prove that
this is something that snaps that's okay
bring your evidence but Sam has no such
thing actually Allah actually let me
give a really clear example a woman came
to the prophet peace be upon him and he
said every time you know people are
mentioned Allah uses the masculine you
know believing man and and good doing
men it's because in Arabic if you want
to include both genders you use the
masculine they don't have gender neutral
enough you include you or masculinity or
masculine words can be gender-neutral in
and of themselves so it includes women
but she wanted to go to the prophet saw
some you know peace be upon and make
sure so she asked what about the women
and the processant didn't really know
what to say because there wasn't a
specific Revelation about that and in
that moment Allah revealed the verses
indeed the believing men or the the
Muslim men and the Muslim women
and the believing men and the believing
women he goes on names all these
beautiful traits that men and women have
and he says both of them will have a
basically a beautiful reward from Allah
so there's no such thing as a Mormon
objects we actually respect and value
our women way more than you because we
are obliged to take care of them and
provide for them and to treat them
actually differently from how we treat
men you're not supposed to go to your
your you know your mom or your wife and
yell at them the way you might yell at a
man because men get motivated like that
women obviously get hurt so actually we
do more Justice to our sisters and our
mothers and our our women than you guys
will ever do and We Know that heaven and
Paradise is under the feet of our
mothers so uh
might want to smack that back in your
face I was going to say Romney it was
that statement that he said um was kind
of ironic too because in the west if
anything women are more like objects
because they go around sleeping with
everybody oh it's like in Islam it's
like they wait till they have a husband
so isn't it kind of like the opposite
but what do I know and bro just imagine
being that brainwashed condition and
program that you think that over here
because you're showing off everything
and basically available it's for anyone
to see for five dollars a month that
makes you liberated bro that's a queen
that's that's independent that's brave
but then in the in the East if you have
modesty and Haya which is like the
shyness to trade that in Islam we
actually look up to that means that
they've internalized misogyny or they're
controlled or they're repressed or
they're oppressed you know that makes no
sense bro
in Islam if you want to be with a woman
intimately you have to give her a gift
you have to take care of her you have to
financially provide for her you have to
be willing to put your life on the line
and die for her protecting her
fulfilling her knees taking her places
doing everything making sure she's safe
in the west 4.99 a month
in front of all of them come on man
Haram
the thing that we were talking about
before
um I want to share this Hadith I had to
look it up just to make sure I was uh
saying it correctly but
uh I'm gonna read it off all right so
this guy is he says uh
Mae's been Malik came to the prophet
salallahu alaihi wasallam and said I
have committed fornication
and he the prophet peaceful doesn't mean
upon Him turned away from him
he said I have committed fornication and
he turned away from him again then he
said I have committed fornication he
turned away from him again until when he
had convinced confessed four times he
ordered that he should be stoned when he
was being struck with the stones he ran
away but a man caught up to him who had
a camera's job on in his hand and struck
him down and he fell down
uh in the process on the piecing
business you'd be upon and was taught
about how he fled when the Stones hit
him and he said why did you not let him
be
so it's like in Islam it's
it's always portrayed as like oh there's
these dire consequences dire
consequences but in reality like yes
there are consequences there are clear
consequences but it also shows of like
hummus for the Creator is and how like
in Islam like even if you did these
things like
it should be between you and Allah like
go repent go repent to Allah like don't
ask for a consequence when you can
clearly repent right now you can clearly
go back to the Creator so it's like I
think it's just it's just in the west
man that we have this
being uh pushed out but again like what
what do I know what do I know I'm just
gonna leave it there
um
all right boys Friday night I say it's
uh we're hitting two hours let's end
this stream soon
um but if you guys have nothing to say
then I think honor is a very special
important message
um that he's been actually preparing for
like the last few days on
me yes bro I think the floor is yours
bro let's not be shy take this
opportunity bro say it as it is
what are you talking about
this guy but you playing around me go
ahead end it up bro
I honestly have no idea what you're
talking about yeah I have no idea but
with this being said guys stay tuned for
a lot of old episodes remastered
Insha'Allah coming up in the new year
God why believe in Islam comparative
religion breaking everything down just
like we did two years ago when we
started this YouTube channel but with a
little bit more knowledge and a little
bit more finesse inshallah
inshallah and with that being said for
everyone who attended everyone in the
comments make sure to like And subscribe
check out Sonny fast's Channel and thank
you Ronnie for coming joining us today
and accepting Islam and giving us the
honor of of being the ones to give you
shahada thank you Sunny for attending
and giving us an honor to share Islam
with you and our viewers in your viewers
as well and with that being said
foreign